it's a book 27 it is already 2016
everybody welcome to the show on the fly
Kelly Ripa and Michael Strahan did not
address his early departure from the
show during Wednesday's episode ET
confirmed that Michaels last day on live
will be friday and made 13 instead of in
September which was initially scheduled
rip returned to the show Tuesday she
addressed her absence I needed a couple
of days to gather my thoughts after 26
years with this company I earned the
right Michael also appeared on
Wednesdays good morning america again
his early exit from live was not a topic
of conversation ABC wants to get back to
business they want to get back to
regularly scheduled program it everybody
in the TV business is asking is Kelly
Ripa going to stay on our show or is she
gonna leave when her contract expires I
know some people are betting the she
will leave others are betting that the
money will be enough to persuade her to
stay but one thing is for sure ABC's
gonna have a pretty tough negotiation
now something else that could persuade
her to stay her replacement co-host a
production source tells ET Kelly will
likely bring up Anderson Cooper's name
quote they're close friends he's an
incredible dancer I'm not kidding
incredible he's amazing with kids I mean
with our kids he shaped really he's
amazing et has learned Neil Patrick
Harris is also in the running and as the
show begins to make the transition it's
likely live won't plan anything
extravagant for Michaels exiting a
source tells ET quote ailments debating
as to how big of a deal to make it if it
seems too celebratory it'll seem
disingenuous due to all the known drama